This right here is my Claude Code
executive assistant. Let me show you a
few things that it can do. Okay, so I'm
going to start off by saying pretend
that it's morning because it's not right
now and use the morning coffee skill to
help me plan my day. So I'm going to
shoot that off. Now, while that's going,
I'm going to open up a new tab and I'm
going to shoot off this message that
says [music] spin up a sub-agent to do
research on the new Claude Code voice
feature and then create both a LinkedIn
post and a Twitter style carousel for
me. It's created a to-do list and it's
getting going on that. I'm opening up
another window and I'm saying do a pulse
check on the team to see if we're on
track for the week and for the quarter.
And finally, one more just for fun,
create me a visualization for a YouTube
video where I want to explain why having
Claude as an executive assistant is
awesome and now it's using a
visualization skill. So what you're
watching right now are four different
agents, 1 2 3 4, all doing things for me
in parallel. And not just for a cool
demo, but these are actually things that
I do every single day or every single
other day. So the first agent's done,
which is our morning coffee, and we can
see this is what is on the calendar for
today. It's crazy that it said March
5th, it's actually the 4th, but still
this is all correct. So it looked
through my calendar, it looked through
my project management and our quarterly
goals and it pulled in urgent action
items. It also pulled in my video
pipeline, so it sees what I'm scripting
and what's in the backlog, and it uses
all of this context as well as
everything on this left-hand side, which
are, you know, current priorities, me,
OTAs, my team, work. We've got projects,
we've got decisions, we've got all this
stuff in here that it's able to look
through. So we've basically given it
access to everything going on in my
business. And now it's able to just plan
out my entire day and I can go ahead and
say yes and it will just block off my
whole calendar. And I really love doing
this because if I don't have to have
that decision fatigue of what should I
do with my next 15 minutes, my next
hour, and it's just done for me, I'm way
more productive. The second one is done,
so we had a sub-agent doing research,
we've got a LinkedIn post, and we've got
our carousel. So right here is the
LinkedIn post which is in my tone of
voice, as you can see. And then if I go
over here to our projects and I go to
carousels and I go to March 4th, we can
see that we have seven slides. We've got
slide one which is you can now talk to
your code editor, slide two Claude Code
voice mode is live, slide three, slide
four, I think you guys get the point,
and then here's slide seven which is the
CTA. Now we've got the pulse check which
is an even deeper dive than that morning
coffee skill. It's looking at all of the
initiatives that we currently have in
progress and I can see each task and the
current status. And based on all that
information and based on our goals, it
gives me follow-ups. So I'm really
easily able to check in on the team and
make sure that everything is actually
progressing. And the last one is our
actual visualization for an executive
assistant. So I would just need to go to
projects, I would go to visualizations
and we should see March 4th we have
Claude executive assistant PNG. So
here's what we got, we've got you on the
left-hand side where you're buried in
work and on the right-hand side we've
got with Claude executive assistant. And
I'm actually going to use this in the
video. So that was a quick demo, you
guys got a little bit of a taste of what
this executive assistant can do for me.
Now don't be overwhelmed by all these
files over here, I've built this up by
using it every day, but I'm going to
show you guys exactly how you can follow
this framework to have basically your
own Herc 2, which is what I have right
here, but it would be for you. And so
all four of these things that just
happened probably took me a minute or
two, and if I was to do each of those
manually, it would have taken me at
least 25 minutes. So if you want to know
how you can build this for yourself,
let's get into it. So today you are
going to be building your own executive
assistant with Claude Code, but I wanted
to start off real quick by just talking
about what most people do and why that's
not really the same thing. So with
something like Claude or ChatGPT, we've
been way more productive because we've
been able to save memories, we've been
able to save, you know, maybe custom
skills or custom prompts. There's still
so many times you've probably thought to
yourself, man, I wish this thing just
knew everything about what's going on.
So in that old way you kind of feel like
you're repeating yourself a lot or
you're giving it extra context or it's
just helping you get maybe like 50% of
the way there instead of 90% of the way
there. But with an AI assistant, it
knows your name, your business, your
priorities, your team, your current
things, it knows the decisions you've
made, and it can also do things for you
like check in with the team, it can
create stuff, it can research, it can
plan your day. And this is the visual
that we just generated together and I
actually like this more because it's
showing that I'm able to create more
YouTube videos because of this
assistant. So the benefits are pretty
clear here, you can save a lot of time,
you never have to really repeat
yourself, you scale your team, and you
could potentially sell this skill.
Because now you understand how to set up
these frameworks with context management
and, you know, memory. And in this
process of building your own assistant,
you're going to get so much better at
Claude Code, which is a really good
skill to have. So like I said, today I'm
going to be showing you guys exactly how
I built this thing and there's four main
phases. So phase one is we need to give
it a home. So that's kind of like the
structure of our project, which I think
is the most difficult or kind of like
the most confusing thing up front.
Because as you guys saw in my project,
there's a lot of folders and in each of
these folders there's a lot of
subfolders, so there's a lot going on.
So it's really important to be able to
make sure that you know where stuff is,
but that Claude also knows where
everything is. Because as you scale,
more and more files will be created,
more and more skills, more and more
processes. After we've given it a home,
we need to give it some life. So we need
to give it some rules, we need to give
it some context about you, it needs to
learn everything about you and what
you're currently up to. After that, we
need to give it hands. So we're going to
build a first skill together and then
we're going to see how we can build more
and more skills and sub-agents and stuff
like that so that it actually gets more
useful at doing things for you rather
than just like helping you think. And
then finally, talking about how we
actually let this thing grow. How do we
improve it? How do we really scale it?
And how do we make sure that this
assistant actually gets smarter over
time and really is leverage for us. All
right, so phase one, let's give this
thing a home. So if you guys have
watched any videos on my channel with
Claude Code, then you've noticed I'm
using Visual Studio Code, which is just
an IDE, an integrated development
environment. It's completely free to
download for Windows or Mac, so go ahead
and grab that and then once you're in
there, this is what it should look like
when you open it up. Now what you have
to do is come over to left-hand side,
click on extensions, and you'll type in
Claude Code and it will look like this.
And all you have to do is go ahead and
install this. When you do that, it'll
prompt you to sign in with your
Anthropic subscription, which you do
need to be on a paid plan for Claude
Code. You could use your API key, but
it's better to just have a fixed cost
rather than worrying about how many
tokens you are racking up. All right, so
once Claude Code has been installed,
you'll notice in the top right there's a
little orange button. If you click on
that, this is where you have the Claude
Code actual agent that you can go ahead
and start talking to. But before we
start talking to it, we still haven't
really given it a home. So we need to
set up a folder, which means you need to
open up your file explorer or your
finder or whatever it's called and
create a new folder. So for this, I'm
just going to be in my desktop, I'm
creating a new folder and I'm just going
to call this EA demo, EA for executive
assistant. And now what I have to do is
open up that folder in Visual Studio
Code. So I'm going to go on the
left-hand side and click on the explorer
and it says you have not yet opened a
folder, this will basically be your
project. And I'm going to go ahead and
click open folder and open that one up
that I just made. So here is my EA demo,
select folder, and now we are actually
in our project. This is the home for our
Claude Code agent. Because what I can do
is open up this little button, close out
of everything else, and now we have our
folder on the left-hand side, there's no
files in there yet. And then we have our
Claude Code agent right here in the
middle that we can talk to. So now the
second piece of giving this a home is
understanding how Claude.md works and
creating our Claude.md file. So if
you've built an agent in an event or
you've built a custom GPT with ChatGPT,
you understand that when you do
something like that, you have to give it
a system prompt. You have to give it
instructions. So that's exactly what we
need to do here and we do that with a
Claude.md file. So the way that this
works is you send something to Claude
Code. And before it actually reads your
message, it's going to load in the
Claude.md file and read the entire
thing. And it's going to do that every
single time.
So the Claude.md file should have only
the most important rules about this is
what the project does, this is where you
need to look for your rules, this is
where you look for context, that kind of
stuff.
Because if you fill it super super full
of random information, then you're going
to go through your tokens and your
context window faster. So what's
ultimately going to happen by the end of
this video is you will have not only a
Claude.md file, but you'll have a
.claude file, you'll have projects,
you'll have contexts, you'll have
decisions, you'll have a bunch of
different folders in here. But the
brain, Claude.md, tells Claude Code
where does everything actually live. So
that's how we stay really organized. So
all we're going to do in here to start
is we are going to come over to
left-hand side, I'm going to click on
new file and I'm just going to call it
in all caps Claude and then  md.
And md just stands for markdown. And so
what happens is the Claude.md file pops
up right here and you can see that
there's not currently anything in there.
So I'm just going to say to Claude,
Hey Claude Code, this folder is for you
to be my executive assistant, so just
throw a quick blurb about that in the
Claude.md file. I shoot that off, it's
basically going to look through the
project, see what's in here, and then
it's going to edit that file so that we
have a little blurb in there. And unless
you're on bypass permissions mode, it's
going to ask you for permission here. So
now it says done, Claude.md has a quick
description of your folder as an
executive assistant workspace. If I
click into the Claude.md, you can see
this is what we've got. This folder is
Claude Code's workspace for acting as an
executive assistant. Use it to help user
with scheduling, task management,
research, drafting communications, and
any other EA related work they need. So
this is going to evolve throughout the
video, you guys will see that once we
start to give it some more life, which
as you guys know is phase two. So like I
said, Claude.md is the brain and it's
going to tell Claude Code where to look
for information about us, which is going
to be in a me file, information about
your business, which will be in work,
information about your team, which will
be in team, and then information about
what you're currently focusing on right
now, which will be in priorities. And it
will also understand all of your rules
like the way you like to speak, um your
style, formatting, stuff like that.
Okay, so I'm going to paste in this
prompt, which you guys will be able to
access for free in my free school
community. I'll have a post in there
associated with this video and then you
just need to basically grab that
markdown file, copy it, and paste it
into here. You can see that this prompt
is pretty beefy and it's going to
basically walk you through and have
Claude Code extract all the information
out of you that it needs to get this
project started. So I'm going to shoot
this off and we're going to see that
it's going to start to ask us some
questions about us. So phase one is
creating the folder structure and it's
initializing a Git repo. And now you can
see that all of these folders and files
have popped up on the left-hand side,
which is very similar to how my Herc 2
project was set up. We've got templates,
references, projects, decisions,
contexts, archives, and the .claude. So
all of this stuff is going to start to
get filled up a little bit. And trust
me, as you start to use this, it will
make much more sense. So now we are on
phase two, which is the interview
section. So first part, what is your
name, what's your role, what's your time
zone, blah blah blah. So I'm just going
to give it some dummy information here.
Okay, so I shot off my initial answers
and now it's asking us more about our
business and our work. So, obviously I
am just kind of giving it some dummy
information to show you guys how it's
going to set up these folders, but this
is where you should really take some
time here and let it get to know you and
give it as much detail as you want
because ultimately you're going to want
it to know all of this stuff either way.
So, take your time here, really give it
information. If it asks you something
and you don't know the answer to it,
maybe just say that you don't know and
see if it can help you brainstorm some
stuff. But also you could just say skip,
you know, I'll set this up later. And
you can see that it might not move on to
the next section until it feels like it
has enough information. So, right here
it asked if I had anyone key, I said
yes, I have one other person and I
didn't say the name, so it's asking what
is the name. And now it's moving on to
priorities, goals, and projects.
Remember that you'll be able to plug it
in real time into ClickUp or, you know,
Asana or Notion or whatever you use for
your project management and your goals
because a big part of this is making
sure that everything it's looking at is
actually current. This is just kind of
the initial onboarding to get it
familiar with your business. Section
five asks about communication
preferences, so how do you actually like
to interact with something because this
can be really flavored to you. And
remember none of this stuff is
permanent, you can always change it
later. And the last section is what do
you want help with? So, like what are
the recurring tasks that eat up your
time? What would you hand off to an
assistant first if you could? Are there
any specific workflows that you want to
automate or templatize? Now, if you
don't know right now, that's fine. Just
say skip because what's going to happen
is I'm going to challenge you to use
this as much as you can. Don't use your
custom GPTs, don't use your projects,
try to migrate everything into here and
just use this. And over time you'll
realize what is recurring and what are
processes that you can actually use in
CloudCode. So, I just told it let's skip
that for now and let's just keep on
moving through this setup. So, now that
it has all of our information, it's
going to build out the files based on
our answers and we're going to be able
to see that right now it's writing the
me file and now it's writing the work
file and now it's writing the team file
and the current priorities and all of
this is going to get looped back
together. All right, so all of this is
set up. We have our tree view of our
folder structure so we can really dig
into this if we want to see what's in
the dot cloud or what is in the archive,
all this kind of stuff. We get a summary
of how everything works. So, if you're
confused about any of this stuff, you
will get a summary and you can also ask,
"Hey, like what does this context file
do? Or what does the archives folder
do?" And it will be able to explain it
for you. But you can see it's populated
this stuff with information about me.
The skills that we need to build are on
the backlog. Otherwise, if you listed
some, it would say, "Okay, cool. Let's
just start building those skills right
now." And as far as keeping the
assistant sharp weekly, nothing required
right now. We have auto memory for daily
learnings. Monthly we'll update this
stuff, quarterly we'll update this
stuff, and as needed we will log
decisions in the decision log. And pro
tip, if you want your assistant to
remember something permanently, just
tell it, "Remember that I always prefer
X." and it will save that across all
future conversations. And then the last
thing it's going to do is an initial get
commit and this is just local. It's not
going to do a actual GitHub repository
out on the cloud. So, this will just
kind of locally store these files so
that you can have some version control.
But if you want to, you could just say,
"Hey, instead of doing this here, let's
actually just do it on GitHub." And then
you would just give it your email, it
would be able to help you sign in and
then it can actually just make the repo
for you and it can handle all of those
future commits and pushes. So, the
benefits of that is that in GitHub, it
basically stores all of these folders,
all these files, which means from any
device you could basically pull in that
repo into CloudCode and you could always
have your executive assistant ready.
You've got cloud backups, you've got
rollbacks, you've got collaboration, and
you've got branching. So, it's just best
practice to put your code base projects
into GitHub. So, let's just real quick
take a look at what actually happened.
So, the first thing I want to look at is
the dot cloud. You can see in here right
now we have rules with communication
style. So, if I open up this, we can see
that it threw in some information about
the way that we like to talk. So, bullet
points, everything concise, no m dashes,
internal speak casual, external speak
even more casual. If we go to the
skills, we can see there's nothing
currently in there. There's nothing in
the archives folder. In the context
folder we have current priorities. This
is everything that I just talked about
during our setup. It also says when this
was last updated, which is nice. We've
got our goals and milestones, which it
says update this file at the start of
each quarter. So, that's good. We've got
2026 annual goal, Q1 2026, Q2 2026,
informal milestones. We've got the me
file, which is going to evolve a lot
over time. You can even give it
information about your background, where
you grew up, all this kind of stuff and
it can use all of that to tailor it even
more. We've got the team markdown, so
anything that you needed to know about
some of the key people in your
organization. And then we've got the
work.md, which has some business and
company information. In the decisions
folder we have a log, so anything major
that happens, it will be logged here
with the date, the decision, the
reasoning, and the context. We've got
our projects, which it created a folder
for each of them. So, we've got
chocolate pistachio flavor, we've got
website launch, we've got West Coast
expansion, we've got winter events. And
each of these have a readme file, which
basically is just a quick description of
what this project actually means and,
you know, the status or any other
information about it. We've got a
references folder, where we'll be able
to drop examples and SOPs. There's
nothing in there yet. And then for
templates, we also have, you know, we're
able to drop in some stuff that it can
reference. And this is just an example
session summary. Nothing is in there for
this session yet. And then the last
thing to look at here would be the
claw.md file. So, earlier it was just
like a few lines and it was very basic,
but now it's tailored towards us. So,
you are Jack's executive assistant. Be
direct, concise, and casual. Here is
Jack's top priority. Here is what's very
urgent. This needs to happen ASAP. And
so, this is getting read every time so
that it can basically keep checking in,
"Hey, is this done? Is this done?" Now,
here's something really cool where the
claw.md file can point to the right
files. So, remember how I said that this
got loaded in every single time you talk
to CloudCode. That means if we threw all
of our business information, all of the
information about you, your priorities,
that would be a lot of tokens. So,
remember that all claw.md has to do is
tell CloudCode, "Hey, if you need some
information about the current focuses,
go read this file." So, that's exactly
what you're seeing right here. It says,
"Hey, if you want to understand who Jack
is, go read this. If you want to
understand, you know, the business
details, go read this." And so on and so
forth. So, that's how we're able to save
tokens here, but still give CloudCode
all the information that it needs. It
will also tell CloudCode what tools it
has access to and how to use them. Right
now, we haven't really set anything up.
And similar concept over here with our
projects. It says, "Hey, if you want to
look at this project, go here. This
project, go here." You'll notice right
now we're at about 87 lines, which is
pretty good. I always try to keep them,
you know, under about 150, maybe 200
max. That's just best practice. Over
time they're going to get larger and
larger, so you should regularly be kind
of compacting them down and pointing out
to other files when possible. Now, this
is a great place to start, but at some
point you're going to want to add some
more files on your own. So, this is what
you've got right now, but what you can
see is in my Hercule version, I've got a
few more. And one of the ones that I
added that you'll probably want to add
is a brand assets. So, in here I've got
fonts and I've also got some images,
logos, brand guidelines, things like
that. So, all you'd do if you wanted to
add a new folder or new files is you
would just come in here, add a new
folder, name it whatever you want, and
then just start a conversation with
CloudCode and say, "Hey, I added a
folder called brand-assets. Just update
your skill documents or update the
claw.md to know that it's there." And
what I'm going to drop in there are
logos or headshots or things like that.
So, all of that can be obviously
customized as long as claw.md
understands that. So, that's basically
the way that our project is set up. It's
now got a home, it's got some life, and
let's move on to phase three, which is
giving it hands, actually letting it do
something for us. Okay, so if I was you
guys right now setting up this executive
assistant, the first skill that I'd
probably build is connecting it to
ClickUp or Notion or wherever you have
your actual like project management or
task management. And I'm not going to
walk through that right now because I
use ClickUp and I don't want to go
through that setup in front of you guys
because it might not apply to you
specifically if you don't use ClickUp.
But basically it's super easy. You
explain in natural language exactly what
you want to do. You have it do research
on the endpoints or maybe even an MCP
server. And then all you have to do is
go grab an API key and put it in a
dot.env file, which you'll notice right
here we don't currently yet have. So,
here's what you would do. I'm going to
go to plan mode and I'm going to say,
"Help me build a research skill.
This skill is going to use Perplexity,
so I need to give you my API key in a
dot.env file. So, go ahead and create
that file for me. And what I want this
skill to do is help me do research. This
is more than just a simple couple, you
know, web searches and web fetches that
you might be able to do already. This is
research that's kind of deeper and it's
also tailored towards me and my business
because it understands the context of,
you know, what's going on and our
current projects and priorities." So,
I'm going to shoot that off in plan
mode. CloudCode's going to think about
it. It might do a little bit of research
to help us build this plan and then it's
going to come back with something. And
what's pretty cool is you can see that
first of all, it explores the project to
see how things work and it even spun up
a sub-agent to explore the structure of
our project right here. And sub-agents
are really cool because they have their
own context window and they might even
be able to use their own model if you,
you know, configure one to do so. So,
I'll touch on that a little bit more
after we build the skill. So, it may
come back and ask you some questions,
which is a good thing. So, here it says
for Perplexity, what model do you want
to use? And I'm just going to go with
sonar for now and submit that off. And
now it thinks it's good and it's come
back with a plan and we can see we have
build research skill with Perplexity.
Jack wants a reusable research skill
that goes beyond basic web search. It's
going to create the dot.env for our API
key. Now, the reason why it needs to do
that is because if you do end up pushing
this to a GitHub repo or putting that
anywhere on the web, it's best practice
to have a dot.env, which is where you
have all of your API keys and you don't
give it to Claude in the conversation
history right here. It's going to build
the actual skill itself, so we'll see
that once it's created. And the skill
instructs Claude to understand the
question, load context, so read through
me, work, team, current priorities,
goals, and anything else, formulate
queries, call Perplexity API,
synthesize, save report, and then
present the summary. Another thing worth
noting is that it's also going to update
the claw.md so that it now knows about
the skill and knows that it exists. So,
anyways, it looked at the API
documentation, it gave us a research
report format. I'm just going to go
ahead and auto accept this plan and it's
going to start building it out for us.
All right, so the agent just finished
up. It said, "Here's what we created. We
have the dot.env, which you can go drop
your API key in. We've created the
research skill. So, if I go to dot
cloud, if I open up the skills, we can
see we have a research folder and in
here we have a skill.md for research.
So, I'm not going to read this whole
thing, but you can see now that we have
this actual skill. And as you can see,
this basically just says when do you use
this skill and how do you actually run
the the of, you know, calling the API
and making the report for Jack. And it
updated the Claude.md to show Claude
that this skill now exists. So, I'm
going to go ahead and grab my API key
from Perplexity and paste it into the
.env. As you can see, I'm just going to
drop it in right here and then save it.
Okay, I put the API key in there and
we're going to test it out. I said,
"Research ice cream events in Portland
using the new research skill." And what
we're looking for here is seeing if it's
actually able to call the skill. So, it
says, "Okay, let me load the relevant
project context and then I'll run the
research." The content has been loaded.
Now, I'm going to break this up and I'm
going to call Perplexity. So, here you
can see it did three different searches.
It searched for Portland ice cream
dessert events and then it searched for
Portland vendor application process. And
finally, it searched for Portland
dessert scene and connections. So, it
comes back with a very concise output,
which is exactly what we told it in the
way that we like to communicate. We got
this information, right? But then it
also says that I saved the full report
to this folder. So, if I go to research,
which it created a new folder right
here, we can see that we have March 3rd
Portland ice cream events research. And
this is a markdown file that has much
more detail about what it actually found
as far as these are different events and
these different, you know, vendor things
that we might be interested in. And it
includes all of the links to all of the
sources that it actually pulled here.
And what's great about this and why you
guys can probably now see that the
folder management is so important
because every time you do research,
every time you generate content, every
time you make updates to projects, all
of that still lives in this project,
which is why it gets smarter and smarter
about what you're doing the more you use
it. Because I could basically clear out
this context and I could pick up right
where I left off because it's able to go
read this file, this research report.
So, that was a quick preview of a skill.
Now, there are going to be some times
where you might actually want to use a
sub agent instead of a skill. Now, as
you guys just saw in the demo, when
you're talking to the agent that you
call a skill, it basically just uses the
skill right here in this context window
with this model with that, you know,
conversation awareness. But a sub agent
basically gets called on by this main
worker here and it has fresh memory,
fresh context and you can even use a
different model.
So, sometimes if you want to do
research, but you want it to be cheaper,
you could just tell it to delegate that
to a sub agent and that research or sub
agent could maybe use Haiku instead of
Opus 4.6. So, that's kind of the benefit
of a sub agent.
So, let me just show you guys real quick
how that would actually work. I'm going
to go back into plan mode and I'm going
to say,
"I need to create that research skill.
So, basically everything you just did
with the research skill, but I want to
create that as a sub agent and I want
this to be using
Haiku instead of Opus just in case I
need to do some cheaper research. So,
create that sub agent for me, put that
within the .claude folder in a folder
called agents."
So, we now have the plan to create that
research sub agent and you can see that
it's going to use model equals Haiku and
I'm just going to go ahead and accept
these changes. So, what it did is it
created the agent.md, which we'll go
ahead and take a look at. And I believe
that it also updated the research skill
so that if I say that I want it to be
like cheaper or to use a sub agent, that
the research skill will actually invoke
the sub agent, which is pretty cool. And
then it also added an update to the
Claude.md file, which now should have an
agent section. You can see there's been
a new folder created. We have agents
under our .claude and then here we have
a research agent. So, if I open this up,
you will see that we have "You are a
research agent for ice cream Fridays.
You receive a research query, call the
Perplexity API and save a structured
report." So, I'm trying to keep this as
simple as possible, but there is
something that I want you guys to notice
about both the agent and the skill that
was just created here. So, these were
created as complete markdown files,
which is fine. But actually, the way
that we need to set up both of these is
using a YAML front matter because that's
where we can actually have the
configuration. So, I'm not going to dive
super deep right now into exactly why
this is, but at a high level, it makes
Claude Code better at understanding what
that skill or agent does, when to use
it, and it's going to save you tokens as
well. So, for now, I'm going to manually
build this YAML front matter by
literally just going like this, going
back into our VS Code, and then for the
skill, I'm just going to paste that up
here and then change the name and change
the description myself. And I'm going to
do the exact same thing then with the
agent. But what I would actually
recommend you do is in your project,
give Claude Code this document. You
know, give it the example, give it even
the URL and say, "Hey, look up on this
page, what is the best practice for
creating sub agent files or creating
skill files?" So that every time you
build me a new sub agent or you build me
a new skill, it does it in the best
practice. So, really the reason I showed
you guys this and the point I'm trying
to make here is Claude Code is smart,
but it's way smarter if you let it do
its own research and then save that
research so that in the future,
everything gets better and better. So,
now you can see I've updated both the
agent and the skill with the YAML front
matter and now it's going to work a lot
better. It would still work the other
way, but trust me, this is just going to
save you tokens and you're probably
going to get more consistent results.
All right, so now let's go ahead and
test that out. I'm going to go ahead and
clear this conversation and I'm going to
say,
"I need you to do some really quick
research for me. I want to keep this one
cheap, so just use the research agent
and find out, you know, how ice cream
events are going in Los Angeles." All
right, so this is pretty cool. It read
through the research skill, it read
through the research agent, and then it
also read through my plans. So, it said,
"Hey, Jack wants quick, cheap research
about LA." This ties directly into the
West Coast expansion priority. So, now
it has all that context, it calls the
research agent with the model Haiku, and
now it's going to go ahead and do that
research for us. All right, awesome.
That research is done. If I open up the
research folder, you can see that right
here we've got our LA report about some
ice cream stuff. So, just keep in mind,
the research report is still really
good. It still has lots of sources, it
still has lots of detail. It wasn't the
research that was worse, it was just
when all of that raw data got passed
back to Claude Code, it was using Haiku
to summarize it and to write this MD
file rather than having Opus do that.
Okay, so we've set up our executive
assistant, we have given it information
about us and our business, we have
connected it with a skill and an agent,
and now phase four is basically just
about letting it grow. Now, I could walk
through some more step-by-step examples
with you guys, but really this is about
customizing it for your tech stack,
your, you know, project management
system, your team, and the way that you
work. So, with my Claude Code assistant
here, because I have all these different
agents now and these different rules and
these different skills, it's just
because I use this every day instead of
using like Claude or ChatGPT on the web.
It gets smarter and smarter over time.
So, right now you're at day one and if
you use this every day, a month from
now, this thing is going to look crazy
different. There's going to be way more
docs, way more decisions, way more
skills, and it's just going to be
smarter and smarter and you're going to
be like living in that thing. So, really
what I would challenge you to do from
here is to only use this. Just like for
the next week, try only using this.
Take all of your Claude projects, take
all of your custom GPTs or, you know,
your gems, whatever it is, take those
instructions, put them into this project
and say, "Hey, turn this into a skill
for me." Use that skill, use new skills,
and every time that you're using the
skill, say, "Hey, this is what I didn't
like, this is what I did like. Update
it, you know, let's let's just keep
making it better and better." And that
same exact theory applies to the entire
system, the Claude files, the reference
files, the project files, everything.
And then like we talked about earlier,
put this thing on GitHub, have version
control, and make sure that if you
switch to a different laptop for some
reason, you can still use your executive
assistant. But anyways, that's all I got
for this one. Now, I'm sure you guys are
all excited to keep building on top of
this executive assistant. So, what's
next is really just to go master skills.
I already made a full video breaking all
of that down and how you can build
better and better skills. So, go ahead
and watch this video right here and keep
using your executive assistant.